Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz tätig und
ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Gespräch durchführen. Damit sind Sie ein Verstandener?
Ja, ich bin ein Verstandener Doktor.
Danke, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Florian Krone.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam beschneiden?
Okay. Frau Krone oder Herr Krone?
Frau Krone.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 540 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
7. Juni 1980.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter und 87.
Und wie groß sind Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 57 Kilogramm.
Okay. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Mein Hausärztin ist Frau Schmid.
Danke für die Informationen. Frau Krone, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin heute hier, weil ich seit gestern Nachmittag starke Schmerzen im linken Sprunggelenk habe. Ja, Doktor.
Frau Krone, können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Also sind Sie erdrückend, stechend, brennend?
Steckend und brennend. Beide.
Okay. Und strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein. Ich werde diese Beschwerden im Sprunggelenk.
Okay. Also sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein. Immer dauerhaft.
Frau Krone, sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Plötzlich, Doktor. Aufgetreten, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie sich Ihr Sprunggelenk verletzt?
Ja, ja. Das Ganze ist passiert, als ich mit unserem Hund im Wald unterwegs war, Doktor.
Plötzlich musste ich dem Hund hinterlaufen und bin dabei über einen losen Stein gestoppert.
Dabei bin ich mit dem linken Fuß nach innen ungeknickt. Sind Sie verstanden?
Ja. Ja, okay.
Alles klar. Ja.
Okay. Frau Krone, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Ja, ich würde den Schmerz mit 8 von 10 der Skala beschreiben, Doktor.
Okay. Und haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe 15 Milligramm Ibuprofen eingenommen, aber es hat mir nicht geholfen, Doktor.
Okay. Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis Ende des Sprechs aushalten?
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie mir eine Schmerzmittel geben, Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe Novaginalergie, Doktor.
Okay. Und leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Nierenversagen?
Ich habe keine, nein.
Okay. Alles klar. Schwester Müller, bitte geben Sie den Patienten eine Schmerzmittel.
Okay. Wir haben Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel verabreicht. Frau Krone, fühlen Sie sich besser?
Ja, ich fühle mich besser, Doktor. Bis jetzt aber nicht ganz besser.
Okay. Alles klar. Darf ich das Anamnesegespräch weitermachen?
Okay. Ja, natürlich.
Okay. Frau Krone, haben Sie in diesem Bereich, ich meine linkseitige Sprunggelenk, eine offene Wunde oder Blut bemerkt?
Ich habe keine offene Wunde, aber seitdem ist der Fuß angezwollen, Doktor.
Und Blut verpasst und fühle sich taub an, ja.
Taubheizgefühl haben Sie richtig?
Ja, ja.
Und haben Sie auch Kribben?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay. Und haben Sie Überwärmung in diesem Bereich bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Nur Schwellungen und Pherkos?
Ja.
Okay. Alles klar. Frau Krone, wann war Ihre letzte Tetanusimpfung? Erinnern Sie sich?
Ich habe nicht erinnert, aber ich denke, es war sehr lange, ungefähr 10 oder 12 Jahre.
Okay. Alles klar.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, Doktor. Ein bisschen. Aber ich bin nicht einmal übel, ja.
Okay. Und mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, ich habe keine erbrechen, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, darf ich fragen?
Nach dem gestern habe ich keinen Appetit.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ja, ja. Ich denke wegen dieser Schmerzen, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt. Ich bin immer gleichgehebt.
Okay. Und haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiz?
Ich habe keine dieser Schwerden, nein.
Das freut mich. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen und mit dem Stuhlgang?
Wasserlassen, Stuhlgang? Ja, ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay. Frau Krone, haben Sie bei diesem Unfall?
Ja. Ihr Kopf verletzt?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe immer mein Spruchgelenk verletzt, nein.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Brustschmerzen oder Husten?
Ich habe keine dieser Schwerden, nein.
Das freut mich. Okay. Und schlafen Sie gut?
Nach gestern schlafe ich nicht gut, Doktor. Wegen dieser Schmerzen, nein.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Beide. Beides, okay. Alles klar.
Und sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ja. Ich bin vollständig geimpft, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Krone, leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bruthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe seit etwa drei Jahren Gift.
Und außerdem vor drei Wochen hatte ich auch einen akuten Giftanfall, ja.
Welches Gelenk meinen Sie?
Linke.
Also Sprunggelenk oder Ellenbogen oder Handgelenk?
Sprunggelenk.
Linke Seite, Sprunggelenk, ja? Ja.
Okay. Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme Allopyrinol 300 mg morgens.
Sonst?
Und bei Bedarf überprofen sind 800 mg bei Bedarf.
Okay. Und haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, vor fünf Jahren hatte ich einen Band-Schreibung-Vorfall im Lenden-Wilde-Bereich.
Noch einen Motorradunfall.
Das wurde konservativ mit Physiotherapie behandelt.
Aber ich habe immer noch Schmerzen, Doktor.
Ich verstehe. Und nehmen Sie auch Ibuprofen dagegen ein?
Ja, bei Bedarf, ja.
Okay. Das war es, oder?
Nein. Außerdem leide ich seit fünf Jahren am Geistamtsyndrom.
Geistamtsyndrom, ja.
Ja. Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Mit Durchfallen und Belagungen.
Welches Medikament nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme Imodium bei Bedarf.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich erinnere nicht jetzt, nein.
Okay. Kein Problem. Ich werde Ihren Hausärztin kontaktieren, ja?
Ja, danke schön.
Gerne. Das war es, oder?
Nein. Ich habe viele klinische Erkrankungen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Ja, bitte schön.
Vor 15 Jahren wurden bei mir Stimmbandknöcken festgestellt.
Deshalb bekomme ich eine Lappadisttherapie.
Und regelmäßig Neuangehen plus Lusttabletten.
Alle drei bis vier Stunden.
Okay. Sie nehmen Neuangehen, Lusttabletten.
Ja, ja.
Alle drei bis vier Stunden.
Und, Entschuldigung, Sie haben auch etwas gesagt, aber ich habe nicht verstanden.
Gegen Stimmbandknöcken?
Ja, festgestellt.
Deshalb bekomme ich eine Logopädistherapie.
Okay, Logopädie.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, sonst?
Ja, ich habe auch gesagt, eine Schlafstörung.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden? Ja, wegen starker Fettlebeigkeit hatte ich eine Magenverkleinerung.
Wann war das?
Vor fünf Jahren.
Okay. Und alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja. Jetzt alles in Ordnung.
Und war das Operation Komplikationslos verlaufen?
Ja, ja.
Alles klar, gut, das freut mich. Ja, und sonst?
Vor sechs Jahren wurde ich außerdem an rechten Knie wegen einer Schlimmbautentzündung operiert.
Schlimmbautentzündung. Okay, das war es, ja?
Ja, ja.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf andere Medikamente ein, außer genannten?
Nein.
Frau Krone, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine neue Allergie haben und wie ersetzt sich diese Allergie?
Mit Atemnot Doktor.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche andere Allergien?
Ja, ich bin gegen Latex Allergie.
Ja, wie ersetzt sich diese Allergie?
Die Allergie ersetzt sich Hautrötungen.
Okay. Haben Sie Unfertigkeit gegen irgendwelche Nahrungsmittel?
Ich habe keine Unfertigkeit.
Frau Krone, rauchen Sie?
Ich bin seit fünf Jahren nicht Raucher.
Davor habe ich etwa 15 Jahre halb Schachtel Zigarette geraucht.
Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Alkohol trinke ich nur am Wochenende. Etwa einen halben Liter Bier.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit 16 habe ich mal Haschisch und Methamphetamine ausprobiert.
Aber das ist lange.
Okay. Momentan nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Das freut mich.
Was halten Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck und beide Seiten Granulast. Es wurde auch an den Augen operiert.
Meine Mutter hatte vor zweieinhalb Monaten eine Brustkrebsoperation und bekommt derzeit Strahlentherapie.
Okay. Diese Operation war vor sechs Monaten oder?
Zweiinhalb Monate.
Okay. Monaten.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja. Ich habe eine Bruder. Meine Bruder hat eine Maggenoperation.
So eine Gewichtsreduktion.
Okay. Wie sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin seit drei Jahren ein Doktor und wohne mit meinen Lebenspartnern zusammen.
Okay. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja. Ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind diese Kinder gesund?
Eine davon hat eine Hörminderung.
Okay. Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Rechtsanwalt.
Okay. Frau Krone, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe starke Schmerzen. Was habe ich?
Frau Krone, Sie hatten eine Verletzung am linken Sprunggelenk.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Wir werden kontrollieren, ob Sie einen Bruch bei den Knochen haben oder Gewebeprobleme, wie zum Beispiel Bandriss.
Deswegen muss ich ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich mit Ihnen weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Werden Sie Röntgen untersuchen oder?
Auf jeden Fall werden wir eine Röntgenuntersuchung machen. Das ist sehr wichtig bei uns.
Ich habe von meinen Nachbarn gehört, dass Röntgenuntersuchungen gefährlich sind für unsere Körper.
Wir werden nur eine geringe Röntgenuntersuchung geben, Frau Krone.
Also kann es passieren, dass Sie momentan schwanger sind?
Nein.
Okay. Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen, Frau Krone.
Okay, danke schön. Bleiben Sie im Krankenhaus, Doktor?
Ja, also ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Aber wenn wir etwas Ausfälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen, Frau Krone.
Okay, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke schön.
Okay, sehr gerne. Ich bin wieder da, ja?
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Ja, okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Eva Heinzmann.
Eva Heinzmann, ja.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vollnachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Eva Heinzmann.
Ja.
Heinzmann.
Doppel n, ja?
Ja, Doppel n, ja.
Frau Heinzmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 39 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
4. Mai 1996.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie so seit?
70 Kilo.
Okay, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Herr Kratz.
Okay.
Frau Heinzmann, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie so seit?
Ich habe Schmerzen, Doktor.
Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ich habe, meine Schmerzen sind in den Finger und Zehengelenken. Beide Seiten.
Okay, also meinen Sie Zehe und andere Fingergelenke?
Ja, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit etwa 4 Wochen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Frau Heinzmann, können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher drückend oder stechend oder brennend?
Ich habe zunehmende Schmerzen.
Und drückend und brennend, ja.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nicht dauerhaft, manchmal dauerhaft, manchmal gehen Sie wieder weg, Doktor.
Als Wellenform?
Wellenform, ja.
Sie haben Recht.
Okay, stranen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, nein. Die Schmerzen stranen nicht irgendwo hinaus.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Heinzmann, haben Sie die ähnlichen Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Ja Doktor, ich habe diese Probleme ungefähr seit 2 Jahren, ja.
Und haben Sie wegen dieser Probleme einen anderen Arzt besucht?
Ich habe meinen Hausarzt viele Male gegangen.
Und jetzt bin ich bei ihnen.
Und welche Erkrankung wurde diagnostiziert?
Haben Sie Ihren Hausarzt darüber etwas gesagt?
Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich irgendwo irgendwelche Gelenkprobleme habe.
Aber wie es heißt, ich keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, jetzt nehme ich kein Medikament ein.
Aber früher nehme ich bei Bedarf ein Neuallgintablett.
Und hat dieses Medikament Ihnen geholfen?
Es hat mir ein bisschen geholfen, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Sie haben gesagt, dass diese Schmerzen beidseitig sind.
Haben Sie dieses Problem an irgendwelchen anderen Gelenken gehabt?
Ich meine Handgelenk oder Ellenbogen oder Kniegelenk?
Ja, letztes Jahr.
Das war mein Handgelenk.
Sie haben recht.
Und damals waren diese Probleme auch beidseitig, oder?
Ja, beidseitig.
Frau Heidsmann, leiden Sie unter Morgensteifigkeit auf diese Gelenke?
Ja, Doktor.
Die Schmerzen sind morgens am schlimmsten.
Meine Gelenke sind dann geschwollen und steif.
Ja.
Es wird aber besser, wenn ich mich bewege oder die betroffenen Stellen kühlen.
Okay.
Und darf ich fragen, wie stark diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10?
Ungefähr 7, ich denke.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass die Bewegung und die Kühlung verbessern sich diese
Schmerzen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie haben starke Schmerzen am Morgen, auch Oedäme, also Gelenken?
Richtig, ja.
Besonders morgen, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Heidsmann, haben Sie noch irgendwelche andere Beschwerden bemerkt?
Ich meine Kopfschmerzen, Seh- und Hörstörungen?
Ich habe keine bemerkt.
Aber ich habe seit den Schmerzen auch Schlafstörungen.
Ich schlafe schlecht, Doktor.
Aber außerdem habe ich weniger Apertit seit etwa 3 bis 4 Wochen.
Und deswegen auch 2 bis 3 Kilo abgenommen.
In welchem Zeitraum?
Etwa 4 Wochen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich habe beides, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Fieber, Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder mit Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen, nein.
Okay.
Frau Heinzmann, haben Sie an Ihren Gelenken, ich meine besonders Finger eine Deformation,
ich meine ein Strukturproblem bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor, nein.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und bleiben Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Ich habe keine Luftnot und Husten, nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor, ja.
Okay.
Frau Heinzmann, besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, ich gehe bei meinen Frauenarzten regelmäßig drei Monate, Doktor.
Wann war Ihr letzter Besuch?
Vor zwei Jahren, zwei Monate.
Vor zwei Monaten.
Ja.
Und alles in Ordnung?
Ja, alles in Ordnung, ja.
Okay.
Und was war Ihr letzter Monatblutung?
Vor zwei Wochen, ja, Doktor.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, an chronischen Beschwerden habe ich seit vier Jahren Sodbränen, ja.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, dagegen ich täglich um ein Prozol 40 mg einnehme, ja.
Und abends?
Morgens.
Okay, sonst?
Außerdem habe ich eine Skolioze seit meiner Jugend, aber die wurde nie behandelt.
Okay.
Sie nehmen kein Medikament ein, ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Und sonst?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe vergessen Ihnen zu sagen, ich habe jetzt keine Probleme mit
Stuhlgang, aber wenn ich Stress habe, bekomme ich Durchfall, ja.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich werde gerne noch dagegen behandelt, aber jetzt erinnere mich nicht.
BS heißt Doktor.
Ein Medikament oder?
Ja, ein Medikament, ein Medikament, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Kein Problem.
Also ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren für die Details, ja?
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden?
Ich habe nicht operiert worden, nein.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie irgendwelche andere Medikamente außer Gelände?
Ja, nein.
Okay.
Frau Heinzmann, haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente oder Pflanzen
oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie gegen Sprofloxazin, Doktor.
Und wie ausreizt sich diese Allergie?
Ich hatte damals einen Hautausschlag und eine Bindehautentzündung davon bekommen,
Doktor.
Sie haben an Bindehautentzündung gelitten, deswegen haben Sie C-Profloxacin eingenommen,
nicht?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Bindehautentzündung, ja?
Ja.
Machen Sie irgendwelche andere Allergien?
Ich reagiere allergisch auf keine anderen Medikamente oder Nahrungsmittel, Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich.
Frau Heinzmann, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich bin Raucher, Doktor, leider.
Seit wann und wie viel rauchen Sie?
Ungefähr 10 bis 15 Zigaretten am Tag seit etwa 20 Jahren, Doktor.
Okay.
Also Frau Heinzmann, wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen?
Wir haben ein gutes Programm im Krankenhaus, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören oder mindestens
das Rauchen zu reduzieren, ja?
Ich freue mich sehr, Doktor, wenn Sie mir helfen können, Doktor.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Also nach dem Aufnahmegespräch können wir darüber wieder sprechen, okay?
Okay, okay.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Alkoholtrinker, ja, natürlich.
Alkoholtrinker ist nur gelegentlich, vielleicht ein bis zwei Gläser Wein.
Also was meinen Sie pro Woche, gelegentlich pro Monat?
Am Wochenende oder treffen mit meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen, eine Verein, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, zwei Wochen oder, ich weiß nicht, ja, jetzt.
Alles klar.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Okay, das freut mich, Frau Heinzmann.
Leiden Ihre Eltern noch?
Entschuldigung, bitte.
Ja, ja, ja.
Leben, Entschuldigung, ja.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, ja, meine Eltern leben jetzt, ja.
Okay, und leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischer Erkrankung, von der ich wissen sollte?
Ja, mein Vater leidet an Bluthochdruck und meine Mutter leidet an Pukakrankheit, Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder.
Entschuldigung.
Und sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, alle sind gesund, ja.
Okay, wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ja, ich wohne mit meiner Frau und meinen Kindern, ja.
Okay, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Handwerker.
Was machen Sie eigentlich, Frau Heinzmann, was meinen Sie damit mit Handwerker?
In einer Fabrik oder?
Ja, ja, ich arbeite in einer Fabrik, ja.
Okay, sind Sie zufrieden bei der Arbeit?
Nein, ich habe ein Problem, Doktor.
Es war sehr nicht einfach für mich, in dieser Fabrik zu arbeiten.
Ich verstehe sehr, Sie haben recht.
Aber wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen, Frau Heinzmann.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Sie sind ja jetzt im Krankenhaus und wir werden alles für Sie tun, okay?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie mir eine Krankschreibung schreiben, Doktor?
Ja, also Frau Heinzmann, zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Was ist Blut abnehmen?
Wir werden Ihnen Blut abnehmen für Labors, Frau Heinzmann.
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig bei uns.
Wir werden einige Werte kontrollieren.
Ich vermute, dass Sie eine Rheuma haben.
Deswegen werde ich Ihnen auch Blut abnehmen.
Und auch werde ich ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen, wie zum Beispiel Röntgenuntersuchung.
Ja, Dr. Römer, Römer ist sehr gefährlich.
Ich habe gehört, ich muss arbeiten.
Ich habe drei Kinder, eine Frau.
Frau Heinzmann, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Also mit einer guten Therapie werden Sie wieder gesund sein.
Also diese Krankheit ist keine lebensbedrohliche Krankheit.
Wir werden die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen und dann werden wir Medikamenthese-Therapie anordnen.
Und Sie werden sich besser fühlen.
Ist Medikamenthese-Therapie funktioniert für mich?
Ja, wir haben gute Therapiemöglichkeiten.
Und diese Therapien funktionieren sehr gut bei unseren Patienten.
Also wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie werden wieder gesund und Sie werden wieder in diesem Fabrik arbeiten.
Ich habe von einer Seite gelesen, es gibt viele Nebenwirkungen mit den Römer-Medikamenten.
Ist das richtig oder falsch?
Frau Heinzmann, wir werden ein paar Medikamente anordnen.
Aber gegen diese Nebenwirkungen werden wir auch andere Medikamente geben.
Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Und wir werden Sie regelmäßig kontrollieren, ob Sie ein Problem haben.
Ja, ich danke schön.
Ich warte auf Sie.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Bitte nehmen Sie einen Platz.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über Sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Frau Florin Krone ist 45 Jahre alt, 1,87 m groß und 57 kg schwer.
Frau Krone stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern Nachmittag bestehender, plötzlich
aufgetretener linzseitiger Sprunggelenk Schmerzen zustand nach einem Sturz vor.
Der Patientin zufolge habe sie im Wand mit ihrem Hund unterwegs und plötzlich
habe sie auf einem losen Stein gestroppert und mit dem linken Sprunggelenk nach innen
umgeknickt.
Die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo hin ausfallen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala mit 8 von 10 bewertet und die Einnahme von
500 mg Ibuprofen hätte keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Die Patientin berichtete über Oedäme, Hämatome und Hypostasie am Sprunggelenk und die Fragen
nach Blutungen, offener Hunde, Parasthesie, Kopfverletzung, Brustschmerzen, Thesis
und Dyspnoe wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die folgenden bekannt Nausea ohne Emesis, schmerzbedingte
Inapetens und schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Ein- und Durchschlafstörungen.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft und letzte Tetanusimpfung war vor
12 Jahren.
An Feuerkrankungen nannte sie seit 3 Jahren bestehende Anamnese.
An Feuerkrankungen nannte sie seit 3 Jahren bestehende Arthritis Ulrica und vor 3 Wochen
Diagnostisierte Giftattacke im linken Sprunggelenk, also Prodagro, in der Knochenboden.
Vor 5 Jahren Diagnostisierte Discus prolaps in ländlichen Wirbelbereich bei Motorradunfall
und seitdem chronische Lumbargie.
Seit 5 Jahren bestehende Reiz-Darm-Syndrom und vor 15 Jahren Diagnostisierte Discus
und vor 15 Jahren Diagnostisierte chronische Laryngitis wegen Stimmbandknochen.
Ich habe die Fachbegriffe eigentlich vergessen, Herr Oberarzt.
Und die Patienten nehmen Alloprinol 300 mg morgens und überprofizieren.
800 mg bei Bedarf gegen Arthritis Ulrica ein.
Chronische Lumbargie wurde konservativ mit einer Physiotherapie behandelt und sie
nehmen gegen Diarrhea und Meteorismus im Modium Tabletten bei Bedarf ein.
Und sie nehmen neu angehende Lutsch Tabletten alle 3-4 Stunden ein.
Gegen Laryngitis.
Vor 5 Jahren sei bei ihr eine Magenverkleinerung, eine Schmerzenkontaktion, eine Schmerzenkontaktion,
durchgeführt worden und vor 6 Jahren sei sie wegen einer Schleimbeutelentzündung,
also Bucitis, im rechten Knie operiert worden.
Sie habe Allergie gegen Novalgin, die sich durch Dyspnoe äußert und sie habe
auch Latexallergie, die sich durch Erythäm äußert.
Sie sei Ex-Raucherin seit 5 Jahren.
Davor habe sie 10 Grad täglich 15 Jahre lang geraucht.
Sie trinke eine halbe Liter Bier am Wochenende und sie habe mit 16 Jahren einmal halbe
Hechisch und mit Amphetamin probiert.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass der Vater an Arteriehypertonie und
beidseitiger Katarakt leider und die Mutter leider an Mama-Kalzinom, die vor 2 und
halb Monaten operiert worden sei und auch mit der Strahlentherapie behandelt wurden.
Sie habe einen Bruder, der eine Magenoperation in der Knie
hatte, eine Gewichtsreduktionoperation.
Sie sei geschieden seit 3 Jahren.
Sie haben 3 Kinder und sie lebe mit ihrem Lebenspartner.
Sie sei Rechtsanwaltin von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Sprünggelenk-Torsion aus, da die
Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin hatte ihr linksseitiger Sprünggelenk verletzt,
beim Innenumknicken und sie leidet unter dem Hämatome Hypesthesie und starke Schmerzen.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Torsion, Distortion.
Als die Verletztendiagnosen kommen Bänderriptue oder Bänderis im Sprünggelenk in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der
Patientin die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung
durchführen. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob dem
Hämatome Blutungen, offene Wunden, Überwärmung vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Blutgruppe, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten
bestimmen lassen. Danach würde ich zwei Ebenen Rundkärntesuchung durchführen, um die
möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen. Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine MRT
verlassen, um die weiche Gewebe, Pathologien zu überprüfen. Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose
bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen und ich würde die
Patienten einen venösen Zugang legen und Analystika, Antiemetika verabreichen. Danach würde ich
ein orthopädisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren. Bei der
Therapie würde ich auch Hochlagerung des Beines, Kühlung, Fixierung durchführen, um die Therapie
zu optimieren. Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise verstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten
Untersuchung fortfahren. Ja, also die Patienten haben nach innen ungeknickt, deswegen können wir
am Tibia eine Fraktur feststellen. Was führen Sie zuerst, wenn der Patient Tibiafraktur hat?
Welche Diagnostik und Maßstaben führen Sie durch? Zuerst würde ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen.
Ich würde unsichere und sichere Frakturzeichen überprüfen. Also Krepitation oder eine Deformation würde ich
zuerst kontrollieren und auch die unsicheren Frakturzeichen wie Oedema, Hämatome, Überwärmung und dann
würde ich eine Zweiebene Röntgenuntersuchung bei den Patienten durchführen, um die Fraktur genau festzustellen.
Können wir mit Hilfe der Sonographie eine Fraktur feststellen?
Ich denke, ja, also nicht einfach, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Können wir mit Hilfe der Sonographie eine Fraktur feststellen, aber es braucht viel Erfahrung.
Wenn Sie im Röntgen des Schuprungelenks keine Fraktur sehen, aber führen Sie eine Fraktur?
Wir können eine CT des Schuprungelenks durchführen, um die Fraktur genau festzustellen.
Aber wenn Sie im CT des Schuprungelenks keine Fraktur sehen, welche andere Diagnostikmaßnahme zeigt uns eine Fraktur?
Meinen Sie am Knochen? Ja, genau. Also ich würde eine MRT für die weiche Gewählepathologie beurteilen, aber eine Fraktur? Keine Ahnung.
Manchmal zeigt uns die Fraktur auch.
Herr Kollegen, wenn der Patient nach Hause geht, was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Wenn wir diese Fraktur mit einer ...
Schuprungelenks ist eine Distorsion, nicht eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Also ein paar Tage würde ich ein Gipsverband benutzen, um das Schuprungelenk zu fixieren.
Also Kühlung, Schonung, Hochlagerung sind sehr wichtig bei dieser Situation.
Empfehlen Sie früher laufen?
Nein, ich würde empfehlen, die Patienten ein paar Tage nicht zu bewegen.
Deswegen würde ich auch eine Anti-Thrombose-Therapie einordnen.
Das brauche ich, denke ich.
Können Sie uns die CT aufklären?
Gerne, ich werde sie über CT aufklären.
Die CT gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Tumore und andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung und ist völlig schmerzfrei.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten ruhig in einer CT-Röhre liegen.
Wenn der Patient eine Platzangst hat, können wir ihm eine Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 30 Minuten.
Manchmal sollen wir ein Schmerzmittel geben, um die Organe sichtbar zu machen.
Es gibt einige Kontraindikationen wie z.B. Schwangerschaft oder Kontrastmittelallergie.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen und nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anschränkungen.
Der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Hat diese Untersuchung Strahlung?
Meinen Sie eine Schrallung?
Während der Untersuchung geben wir den Patienten Strahlung.
Wir geben eine geringe Strahlenbelastung.
Was bedeutet diese Strahlung?
Verursacht sie gefährliche Tumoren?
Nein, eine geringe Strahlung geben wir den Patienten.
Wenn die Patienten schwanger sind, ist das gefährlich.
Sonst sind die Schrallen gering.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Wir können eine MIT durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Vielen Dank. Gehen Sie weiter zu der zweiten Stelle?
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über Sie berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Frau Eva Heinzmann ist 39 Jahre alt, 1,83 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Heinzmann stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit vier Wochen bestehender Finger- und Zehgelenke
Schmerzen vor.
Bei der der Patienten zufolge seien diese Schmerzen drückend, brennend und wellenförmig.
Die Schmerzen wurden immer schlimmer.
Die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo ausstrahlen.
Die Patienten berichteten, dass sie ähnliche Beschwerden vor zwei Jahren hatten.
Würden Sie Ihre Ausstrahlungsdienste wiederholen?
Die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo ausstrahlen.
Die Patienten berichteten, dass sie seit zwei Jahren diese Schmerzen leiden.
Momentan haben sie gegen diese Schmerzen keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Früher haben sie gegen diese Schmerzen Novalgin Tabletten eingenommen.
Die Einnehmer von Novalgin hätten eine weniger Rinderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Sie erwähnten, dass die Schmerzen immer symmetrisch seien.
Sie erwähnten, dass die Schmerzen immer bilaterale seien.
Sie berichteten über die Steifigkeit an den Gelenken.
Sie berichteten, dass sich die Schmerzen bei der Bewegung und Kühlung verbessern.
Sie berichteten, dass sie morgens unter Ödeme und starke Schmerzen leiden.
Wie lange dauert die Morgensteifigkeit?
Herr Oberst, Sie haben diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Aber nach dem Arztgespräch werde ich diese Frage gerne stellen.
Diese Frage ist sehr wichtig für Räume, die man sehen muss.
Sie haben recht, Herr Oberst.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzkala mit 7 von 10 bewertet.
Die Fragen nach Kopfschmerzen, also Cefalgie, Sehstörungen oder Höchstörungen wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgen...
Aber Sie haben gefragt, ob es systemische Wirkungen gibt, ob es trockene Augen, trockene Haut, Herzrasen oder Herzstopperen gibt.
Sie haben recht. Ich habe nur Kopfschmerzen und Sehstörungen gefragt.
Sie haben recht. Ich habe diese Fragen vergessen zu stellen, Herr Oberst.
Okay, gehen Sie weiter.
Danke.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgen bekannt.
Schmerzbedingte Insomnie.
Seit 3 bis 4 Wochen bestehende Inapetens.
Gewichtsabnahme von 2 bis 3 kg innerhalb von 4 Wochen.
Und seit Langem bestehende Diarrhe.
Wegen Stress.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft und sie besuche ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig.
Ihre letzte Monatsblutung war vor 2 Wochen.
Anvorerkrankungen nannte sie seit 4 Jahren bestehende Pirosis und seit Jugend bestehende Skoliose.
Sie nehme Omeprazole 40 mg morgens ein.
Sie nehme kein Medikament gegen Skoliose ein.
Sie sei bisher noch nie operiert worden.
Sie habe Allergie gegen Ciprofloxacin, die sich durch Exanthem äußert.
Sie habe an Konjunktivität gelitten.
Deswegen habe sie Ciprofloxacin eingenommen und diese Allergie wurde damals festgestellt.
Sie sei Raucher und sie rauche 10 bis 15 Zigaretten täglich seit 20 Jahren.
Sie trinke 1 bis 2 Gläser Wein am Wochenende und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass die Mutter an Diabetes mellitus leide und der Vater an arterialhypertonie leide.
Sie sei Einzelkind, verheiratet und sie habe 3 gesunde Kinder.
Sie wohne mit ihrer Familie.
Sie sei Handwerker in einer Fabrik und habe Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Rheumatitis Arthritis aus, da die Patienten typische Symptome dafür aufweisen,
dass die Patientin unter Gelenkschmerzen leidet,
in verschiedenen Gelenken, Morgensteifigkeit, Morgenödeme und diese Symptome sprechen für eine Rheuma.
Als Differenzierdiagnosen kommen Arthritis Ulrica, Psoriathik Arthritis, Arthrose in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der Patientin die Vitalparameter überwachen
und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Ödeme, Hautfarbeveränderungen, Deformation, Überwärmung oder Knoten an den Gelenken vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild CAP BSG, Rheumatoid Faktor, CCP, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyse,
CCPA bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Zweiebene Röntgenuntersuchung, den Finger, den betroffenen Fuß,
eine bilaterale Zweiebene Fußgelenk oder Seegelenk Röntgen durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Wie zum Beispiel Gelenkspaltvereinkung oder Deformation bei der Gelenk.
Ggf. würde ich eine CT veranlassen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu überprüfen.
CT oder MRT, welche Diagnostiksysteme führen Sie durch?
Ich würde ein MRT durchführen, um die weiche Gewebepathologie zu beurteilen.
Oder wenn es eine sehr fortschrittene Gelenkverengung oder andere Strukturprobleme bei den Gelenken gibt,
würde ich auch eine CT durchführen, um die mögliche Pathologie zu beurteilen.
In diesem Fall sind Röntgen des Gelenks und MRT des Gelenks wichtig.
Ihr habt schon die Zeit vergessen, Herr Oberarzt.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde einen Venosinzugang legen und Analgetika verabreichen.
Ich würde als medikamentöse Therapie Methoterexat anordnen und auch Foliexäure,
um die Nebenwirkungen vom Methoterexat zu vermeiden.
Danach würde ich ein rheumatologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren.
Ich würde Lebensstillveränderungen, wie zum Beispiel Rauchen aufhören,
mit Nikotinkarenz verabreichen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vergehenweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Führen Sie in diesem Fall Elektroneuromyografie durch?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher für einen Detail zu diesem Thema. Ich werde es nach der Prüfung recherchieren.
Wenn Sie an die Diagnose Diabetes Neuropathy denken, oder wenn der Patient Handgelenk schmerzen und denken Sie auch an Karpaltune-Syndrom,
würden Sie eine Elektroneuromyografie durchführen.
Können Sie eine Elektroneuromyografie machen?
Nein, leider nicht.
Bestimmen Sie in diesem Fall Halsäure?
Ja, das ist auch wichtig. Als die Diagnose der Französisch-Fransösisch-Diagnose kommt, kommt auch eine Artitis-Urika.
Deswegen sollen wir Halsäurewerte bestimmen.
Führen Sie eine Doblix-Omographie durch?
Die Patientin leidet unter großsehiger Schmerzen.
Wir sollen eine Doblix-Omographie durchführen, um eine PAVK auszuschließen.
Bei der PAVK können wir auch Schmerzen in den Füßen feststellen. Das wäre sinnvoll.
Können Sie uns eine Doblix-Omographie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über Doblix-Omographie aufklären.
Doblix-Omographie ist eine spezielle Ultraschall-Untersuchung.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die durch Blutstörungen, Stenose oder Thrombose zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung ist sowohl schmerzfrei als auch strahlenfrei.
Wir sollen vorher die zu untersuchende Körperregion mit einem Gel einschmieren, damit der Schallkopf fehlerfrei arbeitet.
Die Ultraschallwelle macht die Gefäße sichtbar und wir können die Gefäße auf einem Monitor sehen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20-30 Minuten. Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen und nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anverschränkungen.
Der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Ok, Herr Kollegen, ich habe keine Frage. Gehen Sie auf unser Infodesk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikate.
Danke Ihnen, Herr Oberst. Sie sind sehr nett.